[Music]
this town's buzzing who's got Oscar
fever me neither man that's kind of
thing they say on Entertainment Tonight
who's got us two fever no one has Oscar
fever no no body temperature is not
raised right the Oscars no Oscars coming
up in a few days and this this just came
out it was in the paper today it turns
out guess what the typical Academy
member who votes for the Oscars votes
for who wins who loses is in their
mid-60s yeah that's that's good news for
the movie Extremely Loud and Incredibly
Close because it's the only movie they
can see and hear
older people here not clapping you like
him
and why did I have to unwrap my lozenge
before the show Republican Republican
campaign is in its seventh year now I
believe yeah they've had I think 165
debate oh it started sometime in 1966 so
and now the the rhetoric is getting very
heated this is the latest I don't if you
hear what Newt Gingrich said Newt
Gingrich called President Obama the most
dangerous president in US history then
he said on the dance floor
I thought he I thought he was against
him no he's four oh wow Mitt Romney's in
the news it's being reported that Mitt
Romney's campaign is spending cash twice
as fast as they're earning it yeah so
hey turns out he is just like huh I
thought this was fascinating a new
article just came out a new article
claims that if Abraham Lincoln ran for
president today he could not get elected
as a Republican yeah mainly cuz if
Lincoln tried freeing the slaves other
Republicans would say Abraham Lincoln
bad for small business
[Applause]
exactly but tape it today yeah out of
the beard wouldn't help no no no no one
likes a beard
political analysts are saying that the
key voting bloc this election will be a
group of women called birth control moms
that's the key voting bloc the birth
control moms yeah
birth control moms are women who use
birth control but apparently not
correctly
this happened using the diaphragm as a
coaster from Chardonnay
it works over the last few months Home
Depot is reporting record profits record
profits for Home Depot home just hold
your applause for later
[Laughter]
[Applause]
whole audience dad what does that mean
for us
do we get that
no I'll try that again folks I don't
know if you heard the latest feel
grapevine but Home Depot is reporting
record profits and
yeah
so Batman yeah Home Depot said they'd
like to share the profits with their
employees but even they can't find them
Taco Bell news ladies and gentlemen Taco
Bell that was unprompted though he's got
a good one now hold on wake up I know
where the bells going
[Applause]
Taco Bell is about to unveil a new
slogan yeah the new slogan will be think
outside the bun and within 20 feet of a
toilet
[Applause]